hey you guys movie retrospective time
doing another stephen king adaptation
this one uh overwhelmingly won the
patreon poll and it's easy to see why i
had actually seen this movie probably
several years ago i think i saw it when
it came out i didn't see it in the
theater or anything like that it came
out in 1992.
uh but i saw it a few years ago and i
remember i was like wow that's like
that's pretty bad or is pretty like
ridiculous or whatever but when i
rewatched it for this i was like wait a
minute this is terrible but also
kind of awesome this movie is
batshit insane it is batshit insane i
mean seriously
yeah i guess you could say it is
i yeah i just got done watching it it
was it's
it's kind of standard for the time it's
just kind of mediocre in a certain ways
the acting is pretty cheesy the
dialogue's terrible a bunch of [ __ ]
implausible [ __ ] happens in it
but it's stephen king and i can really
see his writing in it oh yeah big time
that's that's the way some of his books
are if you were to see him directly from
those pages onto a movie this is what it
would be
it's entertaining
i will give it that yeah it's
entertaining
it's kind of like a basically a [ __ ]
vampire movie but it's really about like
where cats i guess yeah i guess they're
kind of like wear cats they're werecats
that can actually be killed by regular
ass domestic cats yeah and actually the
hero and best character in this movie
is a hero cat yeah there's clutches it's
about this boy and his mom they're wear
cats and they're in this like an
incestuous relationship because they
think they're the last of them
and
or maybe that's just the excuse they
yeah maybe they just like bonking one
another yeah they're immortal aren't
they i was in these i was under the
impression see i'm not entirely sure
there's a lot about the lore of these
sleepwalkers which i'm not really sure
why they're called sleeping walkers that
didn't make any sense like i said did he
get that confused with skin walkers
because these are kind of more like skin
walkers because they're like
shape-shifting
monsters right that are they're kind of
like vampires but they're kind of like
life force sucking vampires but the only
life force that is nourishing for them
apparently is from female virgins yeah
and i think they try to tie it back to i
think ancient egypt in the very
beginning but didn't they have like the
ancient egyptians yeah i think that
types i think yeah i think they kind of
made like a lame attempt to yeah
and then then like uh it's kind of like
also a little bit like [ __ ] cat
people remember there was an incest
thing going on in cat people yeah i was
thinking about so
it's kind of
you can see there's some inspiration
there i think and then kind of a lame
attempt they tried to cobble this
together into some kind of a
monster lore
it didn't really work no i wouldn't say
no it didn't really work in terms of
like what kind of monster is this we
don't [ __ ] know
like i said it's essentially a wear cat
but it's a bearcat vampire when you see
them in their final form it kind of
looks more like a weird sleestacky type
godzilla maybe
it looks more reptilian i'm like that is
not that's not reading as a cat to me no
i don't look like a touhou [ __ ]
monster or something that should be
fighting godzilla at the very end the
some of the practical effects are pretty
good for the time other ones are kind of
questionable but like i said the movie
is already so [ __ ] bizarre
it's already going out there so far you
don't really give a [ __ ] that it's got
shitty
effects i mean the cgi is awful but i
mean a lot of the a lot of the cgi from
1992 was kind of awful but i think even
by 1992 standards
the face morphing yeah particularly i
mean this wasn't i think this movie cost
what 15 million i think it cost 15.
those days yeah with all the corruption
and [ __ ] all the [ __ ] money
laundering that was going on 15 million
was pretty [ __ ]
nothing but i'll tell you one thing you
know from from 92 this would have been a
movie that you basically read it from
the [ __ ] vhs from blockbuster you get
this from blockbuster or showtime video
you your buddies are about half drunk
anyway and you just look at the cute
girls
yeah and you're in high school that's
that's i kind of feel like um manchin
amick who was in this and was kind of it
was big at this time because she was in
uh twin peaks as well in the show that
was the mom so no no that was the that
was the girl um the mom is uh alice
kriege
she was in ghost story and she was the
board queen yeah that's right that's
right yeah yeah yeah queen she was hot
so well yeah so in in that sense you
could be like well you know that's his
mom but still
this is uh this is teenage boy fantasy
horror [ __ ] no all that [ __ ] they're
just supposed to be weirded out and
they're just supposed to go yeah she's
pretty hot
that's it if my mom was out here
yeah i banged your mind i did bang your
butt
like that you know that bill intense
[ __ ]
some of my listeners know we're talking
about music this is yeah
playing that game all the time my buddy
steve coming to high school he [ __ ]
you know i beg your mom right
dude did you do that
you're bullshitting me yeah well yeah
sometimes i thought or am i
i got back at him and i kept saying that
i was going to [ __ ] his sister and then
you go dude that's my sister that's my
mom well then he'd get all like yeah
he'd get all buttered that's that sounds
okay
that's how games boys play
but yeah so yeah so there there is a lot
of incess in this interestingly enough
so this was directed by mcgarris
and uh he went on to helm many many
stephen king adaptations he did uh the
original uh tv series the stand he did
uh that shining adaptation the tv one
that you like so much that yeah that i
don't like yeah look i'm gonna see i
liked it so much
she tries to put words in my mouth like
i'm saying that [ __ ] was a masterpiece
but it's not what that was the [ __ ]
kubricks is a masterpiece and it is true
to the story that's what wendy would
have saw nobody else okay
the television one
wasn't it
it wasn't bad for tv
it wasn't bad for tv
it's about like the old [ __ ] stand
that was also tv if i remember correctly
yeah it's just that's that was more
complete that was pretty much verbatim
the book
yeah which like i said and i and i've
said this before i think that's why it
didn't work but which the shining would
not make a good movie if it was verbatim
or it wouldn't make a good series either
yeah if i made them from the book it
would not make a good like i said and
that's no [ __ ] on that because i love
that book a great book but that's not
and i love kubrick's movie kubrick but
kubrick kubrick
movie the [ __ ] out of that book you
cannot do any better than that if you
put all the details from the book in the
movie it spoils itself yeah and you end
up with the tv series yeah if you want
to see the book on tv see the tv series
that's what the book is yeah because
it's very very literal oh yes literal
um yeah and like i said that's why i
think it doesn't work it doesn't work no
well since we're talking about sleep
park since we're talking about cat
people pookie is over there right now
yeah right pulling all of them pulling
all of the books off i'm on the show too
books [ __ ] y'all books yeah she pulls
them all out and makes like she's very
busy over there she's just like dude
but yeah so uh so yeah we have so mick
garris this was actually the first
stephen king adaptation that he directed
prior to this he had done critters 2
and he did psycho 4 which i'm not going
to [ __ ] on because i actually like that
movie
yeah
also a lot of also a lot of incest going
on in that movie yeah shout out so
interesting
listeners sent us a [ __ ] complete all
four of those movies on uh the whole
collection and every one of those movies
is good
i like yeah i like all of this like it's
a solid series but yeah so um but i will
say that mick garris
uh even though and he did some okay like
stephen king adaptations later on like i
said he's riding the bullet which was
okay um and he did like a bunch of other
ones but
he was also the creator of masters of
horror
um although i will note that the two or
three episodes of masters of horror that
garris directed were like my least
favorite ones so you know um
stop it pokey she's not gonna get that
[ __ ] off camera
we'll pick it up and put it over there
no she's like she's like keep falling
all the time yeah and then she knows i'm
saying no and she's like i don't care
yeah she's like i like it looks better
and uh and yeah and this was also the
first stephen king movie that was just
based on i mean stephen king just wrote
the screenplay this wasn't based on like
an existing property of his i think he
had originally written this as kind of
like um
an unpublished short story but then he
was like no i'm gonna do i'm just gonna
go straight screenplay with this so he
actually wrote this for the screen this
wasn't based on something that he had
really written prior um so
you know so this is kind of like this is
after um maximum overdrive his
directorial debut on which he has
said on many occasions that they were
all so coked up on that movie that they
are amazed that they even got it done
that one is also kind of batshit crazy
and so bad it's good this one actually
might be crazier just because the
concept of it and some of the stuff that
happens in it is just so
nuts and it's the weird thing about this
movie is that it's really
the tone of it is very strange because
it kind of starts out
with you have this opening scene which
is actually kind of creepy
where you have two cops one of whom is
played by an uncredited mark hamill yeah
i noticed that with a big brushy ass
mustache yeah i waited for his names to
be in the credits it never was no he was
a and he was just in this he's like uh
he's in it for like two minutes yeah um
but yeah so they come across this uh
seemingly abandoned house with all of
these dead cats like hanging outside
which
those were actual real dead cats they
obviously didn't kill them for the movie
um but they got them from the pound yeah
and so uh so this kind of so there's a
lot of like cat
death in this one which which really
kind of bothers me even though like i
said the cats are kind of the heroes of
this much like in cat's eye now that i'm
thinking about it the also stephen king
movie
where uh general was kind of a hero too
but so so it's a great opening scene
where these two cops they see all these
dead cats and then they go in the house
there's the obligatory cat jump scare
where like a live cat jumps out of a
closet or whatever and then yeah well
that's
it's it's the law you have to have that
and you're down in your 80s or 90s
horrible
there's like little interns around this
and i picture that like every time i see
a horror movie like that that hasn't
jump scared like
the kitty's like oh my god
what's happening cat's not jumping it
was thrown i'm airborne
but yeah so so there's a cat jump scare
and then
there's a desiccated dead body jump
scare like this body i don't know if
like the before the wear cats like left
this house they spring-loaded this dead
body to like pop because like a joke or
something yeah because it's like
basically they open the thing and like
the dead body pops out the body also
screams did you hear that yeah
i think they were trying to get people
in the audience to [ __ ]
you have to understand that during this
era and i'm what i must say is totally
true
because i grew up during this era we
were watching these things thinking
horror movies of this era especially the
cheaper ones were basically haunted
houses that you watched on television
yeah that's what that's what you weren't
supposed to think too much yours thing
much better like it's like going through
the haunted house yeah it's like nothing
really nothing really had to make much
narrative sense um you know as long as
you kind of had something to string
along yeah string together yeah like
just scenes between you know the monster
attacks and the gore and stuff like that
you were probably golden
um but yeah so
so they kind of opened with that and
that opening scene was supposed to take
place in california somewhere
after which we jump forward to
travis indiana
if that's where it's supposed to be even
though it's clearly still california
because i'm pretty sure indiana doesn't
have big mountains in it like that but
you know what i mean okay i don't know
why they didn't just make it another
town in california but whatever so now
they're in indiana
so uh so charles the werecat son
and mary the werecat mom
are have moved to this new town because
i guess the whole thing is that they're
like nomadic right so
they're
you're led to believe that these are the
last two of whatever the hell species
this is um all the other ones have been
wiped out presumably by house cats like
over the history of the world because
house cats are like their mortal enemies
right so these are the only two around
and
i'm not even sure if this is gone into
like in movie universe or if i just know
this because i read like the wikipedia
page about it
but
what they do is that only the males of
the species
can go after
human virgin women girls
and suck out their life force and then
they have to have sex with the female
werecats to pass on the essence which
seems very convoluted to me yeah it's a
strange thing so he has to feed his
mom his mom by killing virgins and heps
and then he has sex with her and then i
guess like the the virgin life force
like shoots out his dick or something
it's just like in caffeine
did you know this was like cat people it
is like yeah it is a lot like cactus
yeah people had to have sex with each
other in order to regain human form
or was it the way around yeah to regain
human form you had to kill a person
and then it was you killed a person if
you had sex if you had sex you turned
into a cat yeah i remember that had to
kill a human being to turn him back into
a human
that's how that went so it's okay
the only the only time you uh uh in cat
people
a cat person could have sex and not turn
into a cat is with when it was with the
head sex with another cat people
and how often does that happen right and
most of these cat people were related to
each other
yeah so
you know dude was like banging his
sister
yeah so his sister was natasha kanski
yeah and again like i said
it's it's creepy and weird like you know
don't have sex with your mom you guys
but
um you know if your mom looks like alice
kriege then
that guy is still against it it's still
it's still against still you shouldn't
i think it's still against uh instinct
to do that
it generally is unless you're uh
unless you're a freak
to do that but yeah so even though
presumably these are the last two these
are cases no i don't think that's
against their instincts so that's the
thing that's true because cats just
they're not they're not super picky yeah
you gotta so that's the thing you gotta
remember when you watch this movie
they're talking about they're getting
all the cessation but they're not humans
not even close
they're these cats well yeah if that's
the way you want to excuse it but i'm
just saying if incest movies bothers you
there's a lot of events
and it's like you know i mean a lot and
they and like i said even though you're
kind of led to believe that these are
the last two of the species and he's
like oh you know my magic dick has to
like shoot the virgin soul juice like
into you i guess yeah um but
despite that
they don't really seem i mean they seem
pretty like jazz about doing it no
they're into it yeah they're super super
like i'm saying they're they're not
humans yeah they're
they're another species
so it doesn't it doesn't really so it's
supposed to it's been
no it was written to weird you out yeah
it was written to to be weird as [ __ ]
but it wasn't weird to them they weren't
humans
yeah that's true you're right another
weird thing that it tries to do okay so
the first part of this movie like i said
the first part of this movie is kind of
like your standard you know 80s 90s
horror movie kind of thing and it's like
it's pretty effective like as far as it
goes like i said they kind of weird you
out with the incest thing they've
creeped you out with like all the dead
cats and the desiccated corpse and then
and everything like that so then
you're led to believe uh at first that
charles who goes to you know the height
the new high school or whatever and goes
after
they kind of the first scene where they
established that he's after this girl
tanya um played by match and amec
however you pronounce her name i'm not
sure i'm pronouncing it right but um
yeah but so he's like looking at her
like mooning at her in the yearbook and
then like carving a t into his arm as
one does
and um so
they're almost trying to set it up like
he's actually gonna fall in love with
this girl and then there's gonna be like
some in there's gonna be like um
conflict with his mom because mom was
like no we need to eat her and then he's
like no mom i love her that's how you
think that it's gonna go because they
kind of set it up they kind of set it up
like these are sympathetic monsters
right because you know uh the [ __ ]
charles bryant he's played by brian
krause by the way um is up in front of
class like telling a story about these
sleepwalkers and decide oh they're
lonely and everything like that and so
it's almost kind of like they're trying
to set it up like one of the old
universal monster movies where it's a
monster but you're supposed to like feel
bad for them but then that's what i'm
saying about this being tonally strange
is that they kind of set it up like that
which might have made an interesting
story actually um you know not super
original but
you know to kind of feeling sorry for
the monster and he like actually falls
in love with the girl they're supposed
to eat and blah blah
but
it doesn't really do that because it
kind of sets it up like that but then
there's a scene where he goes out on his
first date with tanya like they go to
the cemetery and they're doing grave
rubbings and taking pictures and
everything like that
[Laughter]
well and of course they make that joke
too it's like your mom will want to know
there's been some rubbing going on you
know yeah so uh so yeah there's that so
after that like at that scene he just
goes totally into like monster freddy
krueger in the later nightmare on elm
street i'm going to make jokes about
everything roll so he's like totally not
sympathetic at all so it's like really
strange because i can't
yeah because i kind of feel like that
one scene although i have to say that i
think there's a scene before that where
there's like this big car chase because
it was like the 80s 90s you had to have
a car chase in your movie it was again
it was the law just like a cat jump
scare
so they have um
this big car chase
and at some point charles gets pulled
over by his one of his teachers at
school who's played by glenn shattucks
who played otho and beetlejuice
and basically the teacher is like hey i
know you're not who you say you are
because your records are faked and
everything like that but he's like but i
won't tell anybody if you let me touch
your dick or whatever like he's a
pervert right yeah and then at that
point like charles just rips his hand
off
and is basically like yeah you should
keep your hands to yourself here's yours
so it's like so from then on it goes
into this like cheesy quippy
gory kind of that's what i mean about it
being
just it just it seems like the tone like
switches on a dime yeah you know what i
mean like they're trying to set it up
like a sympathetic monster type of thing
like oh this mother and son they're the
only ones left of their kind and it's
like they have to eat virgins and it's
like they're going to be all like
[ __ ] upset but like a like you know
more of a sympathetic vampire story but
then like right in the middle it's
almost kind of like it goes creek it
like comes to a hall and then it's like
and then he just starts making all these
dumb like killing people making all
these dumb jokes about it yeah you know
what um
having lived through this time i saw
this movie back you know when it was
newer and it didn't really stand out to
us
they did this kind of [ __ ] back in 90.
true all right
um and it was just because
people didn't take these movies
seriously they were just entertainment
and
i can't describe what it was like to see
these back then
you just kind of expected [ __ ] to go
sideways it started going sideways and
you were just entertained and then you
quickly forgot about the movie
i mean i didn't take themselves very
seriously i kind of wonder sometimes
because at times this almost seems like
it's trying to be a comedy like a comedy
like there's like a lot of slap stick
and like i said there's a lot of like
like cheesy one-liners and stuff like
that but then at the beginning it almost
seems like it's trying to be serious
yeah i think a lot of it has to do with
the uh sensors the censorship of the
time of the time i think if they back in
those days if you lightened the mood
you could get away
like maybe they were trying to kind of
atone for the [ __ ] incest angle of
the early part of the movie and then
they started going wacky with it oh well
it's all it's just a comedy
yeah so they were going okay so we'll
give you more leeway with this and this
and that because this was not a serious
move and i always kind of thought that
maybe that's what they were doing you
might be on to something they're trying
because trying to defuse the movies
dark side
is what they were trying to do yeah
because i mean even
you know you're trying to get a pg-13
rating or something
i'm pretty sure this was our
but
i mean i could be wrong but i'm pretty
sure
we're probably trying to avoid an x
rating
or not getting an r rating although this
isn't super gory i mean there's some
gore in it
but the incest yeah would have been a
little bit
they had to do something to lighten the
movie up i think so yeah about 15
minutes and they're like never mind it's
a comedy
you know freddy krueger made good movie
yeah we'll just do like freddy krueger
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that [ __ ] was
funny
like the first one wasn't funny but like
the later ones like they just i kind of
felt like it would and i know that like
the 80s in the early 90s was kind of
like the heyday of like the horror
comedy and like you said i think that if
there was a lot of humor in it you could
get away with a lot more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
than you would in a serious horror movie
i remember seeing these movies as they
were coming out we were renting them and
it was kind of like one was building
upon another and ripping riffing off
another and another so these these guys
were all making these movies knew about
the other movies being made
and
it was just in style of the of the day
to do
dumb [ __ ] like this movie did
it would have been like okay they're
just upping it a little bit
over what happened last year with the
[ __ ] horror movies so they're just
building on a
on a trend yeah right and the trend was
at the at this time to to kind of
[ __ ]
just jump the shark as you dropping the
shark was was the trend
and the movie jumps just [ __ ] shark
the whole
second half of the movie's a shark jump
as soon as the cop shows up with clovis
the cat and he's talking wherever he
goes he's got the it's it's jumping the
shark yeah it's just completely
completely ridiculous cops got patrol
with a cat in the car they just don't
but i will say that clovis the cat the
attack cat is what he says on his collar
yeah is my favorite character in this
movie yeah
so
this movie's jumping the [ __ ] shark
the whole [ __ ] but it's almost kind
of like like i said it's almost kind of
like i've read some reviews of this and
said i think maybe stephen king was like
trolling us or he was just like trying
to like make cause look at maximum
overdrive for christ's sake i mean i
know he was coked up during this he's
probably coked up during this one too
but
this
like i said if the whole movie had just
been zany from the outset then
i don't know then maybe this wouldn't
have been because i don't know if this
movie is like completely forgotten
but
this seems like a really decisive
divisive movie rather it's it
how you feel about it it's like just go
into this knowing that it's batshit
crazy and it's completely ridiculous
and
you will probably have a really good
time with it you know what i mean
because it's just some crazy crazy [ __ ]
happens in this so so like i said once
the cop shows up with and the cop is
like
the cops hilarious i love the cop too
because he's just like driving down the
street like in his police car
singing these weird ass songs about
people with one ball and
that was actually he was singing a cover
song i remember hearing that song
dr demento would play that [ __ ]
it's just like it's so [ __ ] smart
yeah he's just like singing and clovis
the attack cat is like sitting in the
passenger seat so like i said you know
after this whole [ __ ] happens so there's
like a big car chase where he's
chasing the werecat man charles
and oh by the way the werecats for some
reason can also
change their cars and to other cars
and can also make their cars and
themselves invisible yeah yeah uh so you
know so
so there's that just guys um and also
you can like wound them you can shoot
them you can like stick [ __ ] in their
eyeballs or whatever
but
it doesn't even phase them however they
are terrified of cats yeah so when the
cop
that when the cop car pulls up you know
next to
charles's uh magical changing car
and the little clovis peeks up over the
thing and is like hey buddy i know your
number he's like
a cat
and then his face does that like crazy
like cgi morphing thing which is
terrible which i don't even know
like it's like for a second it's like a
little kid
and then it's like a
a
like godzilla thing yeah a sleaze stack
monster thing look like pogozario
doesn't look anything like a cat
uh fun fact i found this out from uh
minty comedic arts
was that
initially if you guys saw like the
terrible oh the also terrible um
adaptation of the tommy knockers
and you know the aliens at the end of
that
okay the aliens at the end of the tommy
knockers that's what the cat people in
this movie were supposed to look like
but they didn't get to finish because
they were like rushed or they didn't
have enough money or whatever so they
just kind of went a little part of the
way with it so i was like well like i
said so they do actually read more like
reptilian alien than cat people to me
maybe they didn't want to make them look
like werewolves because i was like they
don't even have any fur
i don't know
you know all i can say is to say i don't
have any explanation for any of this
i don't know
i remember i remember now i need an
explanation it's fun it's a fun
entertaining crazy ass movie i remember
1992. i remember the market at the time
i was in the army we were watching this
[ __ ] on vhs [ __ ] in the day room and
[ __ ] probably deployed somewhere
and it this would have gone along gone
pretty much along with other movies at
the time this movie is doing
the [ __ ] that it had to do
to be noticed and survived
in its niche in its in its budget you
know i mean in the market it's just
trying to be
it's just trying to stay afloat in the
market
it wouldn't have stood it wouldn't have
stood out that much of the time at the
time there was a lot of [ __ ] with
zany ass movies like i said this is just
part of a trend yeah you know i mean it
i remember this movie and it didn't
really stand out as being like
a bad movie
it was just another one
there was a lot i remember like i said i
remember seeing it back in the 90s and
sort of being like yeah that was kind of
terrible yeah but then um there's a lot
of them like that though and then kind
of i didn't even remember a lot of the
crazy [ __ ] that happened in it so when i
rewatched it again i was like wow that
was like much crazier than i remembered
it yeah but um you know what i mean but
in a fun way like i said but how you
feel about it
um how you're gonna feel about it is you
know you have to like manage your
expectations this is kind of one of
those movies that it's like super fun to
like get together with your friends and
like have some drinks and every time
some batch of crazy stuff happens then
you know every time a cop gets uh
stabbed in the back and killed with an
ear of corn yeah uh you know what i mean
which happens in the movie every time um
hellboy gets his fingers bitten off and
then his arm broken and himself elbowed
in the face with his broken arm uh also
take a shot uh also i want to say too
there's a [ __ ] ton i mean this has like
some famous this ron pearlman is in this
[ __ ] like i said mark hamill did an
uncredited cameo
um there are ferris bueller's parents
are uh mansion amex parents in this
movie uh because apparently they were a
couple in real life i guess they met on
ferris bueller and then got married and
then they were a married couple in this
one too so they were like the mom and
dad also a [ __ ] ton of horror directors
turn up in this in one scene stephen
king is in it because of course he is he
cameos and all his stuff because he
thinks he's out for his [ __ ] or some
[ __ ] or stan lee or whatever um so he
also thinks he can act
[Laughter]
meteor [ __ ] although i loved him in that
i got a yeah that was that was his best
role but um but yeah so in this he's
literally one scene he plays like the
guy that's supposed to was is like the
graveyard keeper like where the where
the attack happens so he's just like
it's not my fault it's not my fault that
kind of thing and then in this scene i
had forgot i had totally forgotten about
this so he's talking to somebody so he's
talking about who i'm presuming or like
the crime scene detectives and i'm like
that's [ __ ] clive barker clive
barker is in that shot he's one of the
crime scene detectives toby hooper is
one of the crime scene detectives and
then later on when there's another scene
with um
with cops or technicians or whatever
there's [ __ ] um there's uh what's his
name john landis and um who's the and uh
[ __ ] not wes craven who's the other
one who's the other one joe dante joe
dante uh so there's a [ __ ] ton
and you so like i said you can tell that
like stephen king and mick garris
uh we're just kind of like [ __ ] man
we're gonna put everybody in this movie
we're just gonna put all these [ __ ]
uh cameos in there and it's just gonna
be hilarious so i kind of feel like they
were all just like snorting coke and
having a good time yeah they were just
trying to get the [ __ ] done hey man's be
in the movie yeah let's get the movie
done yeah and they were just trying to
make it a fun movie towards the end yeah
let's spice it up some look let's
let's have alice kriege get attacked by
cats and then she says and then all the
cats biting her somehow sets are on fire
and also she has a magical she takes one
of the cops guns and shoots the cop cars
and the cars blow up yeah from one shot
yeah and then like a cop comes out and
he's on fire and he's rolling it's crazy
it's crazy crazy [ __ ] happens the movie
would like i said the movie was jumping
the shark
it had jumped the shark [ __ ] 20
minutes into it so just they just
[ __ ] had fun with it can we talk to
about when the cop gets killed the cop
that owns clovis the cat which is kind
of sad because clovis then kind of like
sits on his chest like oh man and i was
like oh that's so sad but uh so he gets
killed by well initially charles sticks
a pencil in his ear and he falls over
and then charles who's kind of like half
cat people face he's got like the
appliances on his face and then he kind
of like leans into the cop car window
where where tanya is and says the
immortal line cop kebab
yeah in the same tone of voice that the
dude from silent night dylan at two says
garbage day it's just kind of that same
kind of vibe oh my god i [ __ ] love it
so yeah cop kabob uh so yeah that cop
gets killed but it's i don't know why i
was watching like the nostalgia critic
and he did a um like a half an hour uh
thing on this
and uh and it was like super super funny
and he was talking he's like okay so
they had like the pencil in the ear and
then he said cop kabob so when the cop
later on who doesn't who can't shoot for
[ __ ] he's like shooting like that and
then he's like
he's like that and then he gets stabbed
in the back with a corn cob he's like
why did nobody say corn on the cop
he's like he's like that would have been
like he's like he wanted a shirt that
said that i was like oh my god that
would have been like saying it was the
era of one-liners
it was yeah arnold started all that [ __ ]
i'll be back and all that weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know and there's every time
something happens you have to [ __ ] i
think the action move what horror movie
started to do that well yeah because
like i said the nightmare in elm street
uh movies like starting with i guess
starting with the second one the third
one it kind of really got up went off
the rails yeah that was the trend that
they would do that kind of [ __ ] you're
supposed to laugh because you know they
were just constantly [ __ ] it was kind
of like
throwing back to other movies everybody
trying to top the other movie that came
you look at it now it's just cringey as
[ __ ] it really is that was just the way
they did things back then because after
all everything was good or that era not
every thing was good yeah and we're and
we're saying that as like people that
grew up during that i mean when this
movie came out how old was i when this
came out i was 20 when this came out
like i said i don't know if i
did i say this in the theater i doubt it
i doubt i would have seen this in
theater but i'm pretty sure i saw it on
cable like a little bit later on because
even in 1992
i was a little bit leery of like stephen
king's anything you know what i mean
like
if he was involved in a movie yeah um
i'd be like do i really want to pay my
hard-earned money to see that oh by
by the time 92 had rolled around [ __ ]
for the most part stephen king movies
were to be
avoided unless you were to see it for
free or something you're renting it from
a video or like i said unless it was
just
fantastically terrible like maximum
overdrive which you still haven't seen
yet that movie is also bat [ __ ] insane
yeah and you can tell that everyone
involved was coked out of their gourds
um there are some good ones yeah yeah
the bad ones yeah bad ones but you know
like i said he's written so much that
it's kind of like it's hard to [ __ ] on
him too much if he's directly involved
with writing the screenplay or directing
then
you proceed with caution
um because i can't really think of a
good one
that
he was like intimately involved with
yeah he needs somebody else to adapt his
stuff best one's the shining and then
[ __ ] carrie the first carry and then
christine and dead zone dead zone yeah
misery there's a lot of good ones yeah
there's a lot of good wire started um i
put dead zone and fire starter but i'm
just saying if you have like a really
good director and a really good writer
who is willing to tell stephen king no
i'm a screenwriter i know what i'm doing
um you know i'm gonna change some of
your [ __ ] around
then that'll be then that's good just
like i said don't let stephen king
not change anything about your
screenplay because like i said he's a
very good writer but
he's not always he doesn't always know
what works in a book and what works as
opposed to what works in a movie because
it's two different things yeah and his
dialogue
just doesn't work for movies it can work
yeah can i just say too that the that
the equip that
the werecat mom gives after stabbing the
cop in the back
with a corn cob which kills him
immediately by the way is she says
something like
uh
no vegetables no dessert those are the
rules
that's what she says i'm pretty sure
that's what the line is noticed
yeah which makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever
but yeah like i said so
uh i will say that i liked
the cat being the hero of this and
actually several cats because for
whatever reason
uh the werecats
their mortal enemy is domestic cats
so everywhere they go they have like all
these traps you know like little bear
traps and [ __ ] out in their yard to kill
the cats right but the cats just kind of
like sit in their yard almost like
they're biting their time like one of
these i don't know why the cats like
waded through the whole movie like
before deciding okay now we're gonna i
think i guess they needed clovis to come
and like lead them or whatever because
clovis is like the lead and when he gets
there he's like yeah i'm gonna take
these [ __ ] out and then he so he
jumps on him and like i said so
they basically die of like cat scratch
fever because the cats just jump on them
and then scratch them and then fire
comes out of the scratches
and then
yeah it's a it's a crazy it's a crazy
crazy yeah another um
another couple good stephen king ones
were made for tv all right i'd probably
say the best of the made for tv would be
salem's lot the original
you can get that on on dvd maybe blu-ray
but it's out there in dvd i recommend
that one it's a good vampire movie yeah
i love songs a lot and then uh right
underneath that would be a made for tv
series uh the stand which is the same
director as this yeah it's they read
somebody sent us a kind of uh
re-engineered i think blu-ray version
wasn't that a great version of it yeah
and it was great it was much better than
the dvd version the way they'd
reformatted it and everything it looked
a lot better
um
matter of fact it looked you know it
looked a lot better than it did on
television if you saw it on television
which i did i saw it on tufts and
recorded on vhs when it came out it
looked like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but uh the blu-ray version was [ __ ] a
lot better cinematic you could watch it
and then
uh probably coming in third would be uh
the made for tv shining and like jenny
said
you're not talking about kubrick it's
directly lifted out of the damn i look i
didn't love it and um
the acting is fashionable the special
effects are not that good the makeup
looks kind of crazy the ghosts look like
ghosts and it's quite
cheesy but that's what
the book the dialogue and everything the
story that's exactly what's on the book
it's worth
watching if you want to
know what the book was like if you want
to see what stephen king's version of it
looks like because he was so mad at
kubrick famously and it does explain a
lot of the stuff that you see in the
kubrick movie
because you see in the book it gave more
details about who those ghosts were
that you see yeah like all the terrible
[ __ ] that happened at the hotel but like
we've said and we've talked about this a
lot is that i think it's scarier not
knowing because you wouldn't know
there's a bunch of stuff that happened
between danny and and tony his imaginary
friend that's not in
the movie it's in the book and it's in
the shining television series yeah
but you know like i said i i don't know
tony was danny
when he was older
yeah in the future yeah i guess which
like i said i i kind of like he's super
dangerous it was super dangerous
yeah but i like that kubrick just pared
it down to
just what just what because to me
there are exceptions to this rule
obviously horror is scarier when you
don't know everything when it's
unexplained when it's a mystery yeah um
so i kind of feel like
that's what i mean with this particular
movie sleepwalkers i think that
either they should have made it just a
straight comedy because it ended up
being a comedy anyway whether that's
what they intended or not um
or if they were gonna go the serious
route don't one don't explain what the
monster is right from the beginning
because right from the like the very
first shot is like a fake dictionary
like it's from like some the dictionary
of arcane knowledge or whatever it's not
real but i mean and they say oh these
sleepwalkers they're vampire cat
werecats or whatever and kind of
explains a little bit about them and
then it says right there
um you know they're vulnerable to
you know domestic cat attacks and so you
know that that's how they're gonna end
up dying at the end i just feel like no
one should have they should have just
like not explained what they were that
they were monsters or anything they
should have just done it like they were
people and then it's like oh there's why
there's why are there dead cats why are
they incestuous why this that and the
other and then later you could have done
the reveal i think if they because they
came out and said what they were like
right from the beginning it takes a lot
of the mystique away and like i said it
didn't really end up mattering because
it just went in like a straight up
comedy direction anyway um but
i'm just saying that the unknown is
always scarier than over explaining
things yeah um yeah what what and what
kubrick had done
was that in his version of the shining
you only saw what wendy saw and what she
knew and a little bit of what jack
torrance knew
from from the bar scenes
other than that nothing about what danny
kind of knew a little bit but not much
and none of the stuff that was happening
between the ghosts
and like i said to me that would be way
scarier because that puts you
in the same position like what if i took
this job at the hotel and that's what
you saw and you wouldn't know any of the
stuff oh yeah you wouldn't know you
wouldn't know the drama between all
these yeah you'd just be like what the
[ __ ] or that you didn't know anything
wendy wouldn't have known anything about
the [ __ ] house was being ruled ruled
by a [ __ ] ghost who was collecting
souls she had to add to their power you
would have known all that yeah it just
would have been scary and because
randomness is scarier than yeah because
if you can put if you can like um you
know get a handle on something like by
putting it in a box or defining it then
it's not scary anymore yeah what was
this hotel was this like temple of doom
or something because it was built on
ground that was consecrated by blood so
they had killed some indians to build it
you know what i mean it was almost kind
of like a temple of the [ __ ] elites
had to do with the [ __ ]
elite oligarchs and human sacrifice is
being talked about you know basically
and the collection of souls and people
dying on this ground and it
built a [ __ ] evil place
the book is good the book is really good
it is yeah and
the television series is closer to the
book it's just it's just
you can't capture a book you can't
capture the the tone of a book through a
television series particularly not in
horror i think i mean in other genres
it's probably easier
well the thing about horror is that a
lot of it depends on people's suspension
of disbelief yeah if you can't suspend
your disbelief then it's not scary yeah
um and to suspend your disbelief you
have to have you have to at least have
some kind of grounding in reality or
some kind of like way in to
you know your reader your viewer or
whatever or otherwise you're not gonna
be able to scare that person or get them
involved yeah and if you liked the
shining you should see the long
director's cut of dr sleep
that's about danny it was pretty good
yeah the theatrical release was okay but
uh
that long that director's cut which was
a lot longer but was that 40 minutes
longer i think so yeah it was a lot
better
interestingly now that you bring up dr
sleep yeah that was also a like soul
sucking vampires basically yeah which is
kind of like the same thing as this they
weren't really monst well they were kind
of like monsters but they just kind of
look like humans but it's kind of the
same thing they're like sucking out
people's life force the soul-sucking
vampires were also kind of
like the living versions of the ghosts
that were sucking people's souls
in uh the shining though at the uh at
the hotel
the hotel was kind of doing that
so it infer remember that and that's in
dr sleep so it it's part of the same
supernatural universe yeah not only can
living creatures
do that evidently dead creatures the
undead can do that also ghosts
yeah i mean well the thing okay so the
thing about sleepwalkers though is that
i kind of feel like it's
a good movie could be made from this and
i'm not saying that that the movie that
they did make is like pretty enjoyable
because like i said it's bat [ __ ] crazy
and just like ridiculous [ __ ] happens it
and you should just like let it wash
over you because it's just it's
hilarious
yeah it's it's a hilarious
movie like i said i don't know if they
intended it to be hilarious i kind of
hope they did
i think that's the only way they could
have gone and made it [ __ ] pat get
the censorship that they needed to get
past the censors and make the [ __ ]
movie marketable i think they had to do
that
and this just barely made twice its
budget back i think it cost about 15
million to make and i think it made 28
million
it was actually actually the when it
opened at the theater it was number one
the first week and then like the week
after that it totally died
so even in 1992 people had standards
well and i'm just saying i kind of feel
like in 1992
um even though mystery science theater
had been around for a couple of years at
that point although it wasn't like a big
national phenomenon or anything really i
kind of feel like even back then i don't
know if
now there's you know it's pretty
mainstream like people
getting into like so bad it's good
movies but back then
there wasn't as much of that you know
what i'm saying i just feel like it
wasn't as much of a thing nowadays
it seems like the reviews i've read of
this are either
this movie is like so awful that it's
awesome like you know just get drunk and
watch it and it's [ __ ] hilarious
or people think it's like the worst
[ __ ] turd ever
so there's like there's no in between
no in between and i read like a whole
bunch of different reviews most people
are are on the side of this movie is so
ridiculous that it's awesome which you
know which you know i can see that i can
see that there's there's a lot of famous
people in this there's a lot of like
really funny like cameos and just crazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens in it it just goes
if you're in the right mood you'll have
a good time i had a good time if you're
drunk and you're in the mood for it yeah
you'd have a good time yeah it's a piece
of [ __ ] yeah but it's entertaining
it's not boring no it's not boring so i
mean the worst thing a movie can be as
boring and this is definitely not boring
yeah so i will give it that
um so it's got cute women in it yeah if
your girl's got cute guy in it
he's a bad guy
uh
it's got a little bit of everything it
it's not to be taken seriously yeah just
watch it like it's a comedy because it
is yeah
it's a comedy with a lot of gore
and hero cats and who doesn't love that
we love the hero cats it's just trying
to entertain you yeah well like i said
it's it succeeded so
so this is actually if you want to watch
it for free you can watch it for free on
pluto.tv i recommend watching it for
free yeah i mean using all pluto tv with
commercials you can rent it uh you can
rent it for 2.99 i think on amazon but
like i said if you can get pluto tv then
just watch it on there because it's free
and just there's just an ad every now
and then um there's a bunch of uh
stephen king's other stuff on there too
i think sometimes they come back is on
there which mick garris might have
directed that one too because i kind of
feel like after this one this was the
first collaboration of theirs but then
after that mcgarris
pretty much made an entire career out of
adapting stephen king's stuff so he did
a [ __ ] technically not a bad movie i
mean it's got it
the edits are clean it's it's it's a
coherent movie uh it uh it has
it has a little [ __ ]
soundtrack
that that song
but it sounded really familiar i've
heard that that song well the wait which
one the enya one or yeah yeah i guess
yeah yeah yeah you play they play a lot
of that in it
so the score is okay
it's it's this the strings obnoxious
okay it's competent this is not an
incompetent movie
it's it's the topic the subject matter
the tone it's [ __ ] bizarre
but i think it's supposed to be well
like i said the the thing that i thought
was weird is that it seemed like it was
trying to be serious at the beginning
and we're almost trying to have like oh
these poor
where creatures they're the only two
left in the world and they're lonely and
everything like that but then they just
went
they just took a hard left and like went
right into like crazy no they're just
straight-up villains and now we're just
gonna have all this wacky [ __ ] happen
might have happened didn't edit
perhaps you know i'm not although like i
said this came from stephen king's
script and as far as i know
they didn't really change much of
anything because that's why stephen king
wanted mcgarris because the two of them
were like friends a lot of that tonal
whiplash can can be no more than you can
just editing and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
score yeah i can't give you that
so it might have been modified to do
that later
this one it had a like a weird like
throwback kind of thing too in the sense
that everybody in it was like listening
to songs from the 50s and 60s even
though it was supposedly the modern day
which i've tried to give a nostalgia
feel i guess and i guess yeah stephen
king does that a lot in his stuff
because i guess he's really into mixed
stuff in the 50s and 60s and i thought
maybe they were trying i mean
particularly with uh charles the werecat
son uh driving the older cars around
maybe they're trying to show that you
know these uh werecats been around for a
long time and he likes certain things
from the past or whatever i thought you
had 50s monster movies
yeah yeah i kind of felt like they were
werewolf movies and [ __ ]
yeah i did see actually i was watching
one review that kind of compared it to i
was a teenage werewolf like a little bit
yeah which i guess not it's not exactly
like that but i can see where they were
going but yeah so as i said if you want
to have some drinks and have a good time
and watch a cop get stabbed to death
with a with corn on the cob this is
probably the only movie that you will
ever see that in i'm pretty confident
saying that i'm pretty confident
corn kill but yeah so it's on pluto.tv
see there's another one there was that
that was a perfectly good joke laying
right there they didn't even use it it
might have been there if they took it
out
you can't say that you can't say coral
we can have we can show a mother and son
[ __ ] but we can't but we can't say
you can't say you got cornhole
even though he literally did yeah oh my
god all right so yeah it's on pluto.tv
so
have a few drinks watch it and get back
to us like what you thought about
seriously watching is hilarious
watch it is hilarious alright so we will
see you guys on the next one
bye